I'll tell you I would actually watch the
news if Ron Burgundy and his news team
was actually a news reporting channel
until that happens I'm sticking with
cartoons and breaking that but that's
not anymore
anchorman 2 is directed by Adam McKay
and he got wolf Ferrell back in the role
of Ron Burgundy which is one of his most
famous characters in fact it's probably
my favorite film that he has made in
regards to comedies and anchorman is a
weird movie it's one of those movies
where the first time I saw it I didn't
like it and I saw it again later and I
actually started to really pick up on it
and in this movie he got these
characters back except Ron Burgundy once
again is in some sort of an argument
with a news team network filled with
people in which he creates various
problems because he's an idiot and just
won him and Veronica Corningstone played
by Christina Applegate have a kid now
that's creating some drama for him and
when I say drama I mean it's like Ron
Burgundy drama where it's all just a
giant joke there's this new hot shot at
the news network played by James Marsden
who's getting under his skin Megan good
is his new boss not a hard woman to look
at there really is no point summing up
much of a plot in this movie because
what it really is is just a whole bunch
of jokes from scene to scene to scene
that are supposed to make you laugh
that's what comedy is essentially I
guess but this movie really is strictly
that it's sort of like a whole bunch of
skits set up kind of around a general
plot now I really enjoyed the first
anchorman as I said and this film is
still really funny as well it's not
quite as good as the first one but I did
find myself laughing from scene to scene
mostly consistently that's because these
guys are idiots the entire comedy around
this movie is centered around idiocy Ron
Berger teased um all of his newscast
buddies are dumb everyone in this movies
pretty dumb and they all embrace that
spirit and that's why some of the comedy
works because they recognize that this
isn't supposed to be some Oscar winning
formula in which they make a comedy that
will stand the test of time this is
going to be one of the movies that
people make internet memes out of and
that's where this movie exists and they
get that also there is a great
improvisational spirit around all these
guys where you can just tell that they
did seem to seem differently and they
did different jokes here and there and
things work and something stuck and some
things didn't they used the best of what
they had there are actually scenes where
they're just like
trying not to crack up and you can kind
of tell sometimes especially with Steve
Carrell because this guy steals the show
in every scene I love his character
brick
he was my favorite thing about the first
anchorman and he kills it here he's even
funnier in this movie than it was in the
first one he gets more screen time he
gets more jokes he gets the best jokes
in my opinion and I'll tell you why that
is I think that is because this entire
movie as I said is going for really
stupid silly comedy so it makes sense
that the stupidest character in the
movie would also be the funniest because
he is the one who embraces the essence
of this movie the most he's just such an
imbecile that you can't help but laugh
at him and he really does honestly have
all the best lines in the movie there is
a moment in the movie that drags a
little bit where something happens to
Ron that I won't spoil and I felt like
it really detoured the entire movie and
they were barely any laughs for a while
which leads me to my biggest problem
with this movie and that is the length
this movies like two hours long the
first one was like 94 minutes or
something like that that's the perfect
length this type of movie this movie
went on probably 20 minutes longer than
it needed to be and it kind of deflated
after a while and it stopped being as
funny it didn't need to be that long I
will say though that a scene with a
whole bunch of celebrity cameos which I
will not spoil was actually pretty
freaking hilarious that really saved a
little bit of that last part of the
movie but it could have been a lot
shorter is it as good as the first one
probably not but it's still pretty funny
and I'm going to give anchorman 2 a B so
guys if you are a fan of the first
anchorman I'm curious what your favorite
quote for the movie is the one that I
probably use the most is more than
likely sex panther 60% of the time it
works every time
as always guys thanks a lot for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck menage
[Music]
Oh